[Music]  check out Beyonce blue ivy and jay-z  rockin matching outfits to Thursday's  Beauty and the Beast premiere in LA  that's when the last pack of fools like  you know girls dream  thirty-five-year-old shared a handful of  family pics to her website on Monday  BAE's maternity style is on point she's  pregnant with twins and we're loving  this shot of her cradling her belly in a  floor-length green gown and check out  the chic flower embellishments on the  neckline cuz I slit five-year-old blue  ivy matched her mama and a green and  pink dress Beyonce also shared a  close-up of her little ones adorable  braided do jay-z opted for a trendy jean  jacket with a lion graphic and a floral  crest that matched Beyonce in blue how  sweet is this shot of the three of them  J holding his wife's belly and we can't  get over this pic of Beyonce and Blu  getting goofy and sticking their tongues  out at the actual premiere this night on  my screen I'll never really ever  [Music]  you